what is happening in ukraine is a
crime and russia is an aggressor country and
only one person is responsible for this aggression and this
person is vladimir putin my father is ukrainian
my mother is russian and they have never been
enemies and this necklace around my neck is a
symbol of that  that Russia must immediately
stop the fratricidal war and
our fraternal peoples will still be able to
put up with it unfortunately in recent years I have been
working on the first channel doing
Kremlin propaganda and I am now
very ashamed of it ashamed for
allowing me to tell lies from the
TV screen ashamed for allowing me to
zombify  we kept silent
about the Russian people in 2014 when it all just
began we didn’t go to rallies when the
Kremlin poisoned Navalny we just
silently watched this anti-
human regime and now the
whole world has turned away from us and another 10 generations of
our descendants will not be washed away from the shame of
this fratricidal  war, we are Russian
people thinking and smart only in  in our
power to stop all this madness
go out to the rally don’t be afraid
they can’t imprison us all I am
grateful to those Russians who do not
stop trying to convey the truth to those
who fight disinformation and
tell the truth tell the
real facts to their friends their
close relatives and personally to the girl
who entered  to the studio of the first channel with a
poster against the war for those who are not afraid to
protest until your country is
completely closed off from the whole world
turning into a very big north
korea you must fight you must not
lose your chance and it
seems
like his mxg station vimes ai
dont like
times  got older zys engine
[music]
object to the Arabs I want to thank
everyone for the support friends colleagues
it was really very difficult
difficult days of my life because I
spent literally two days without sleep for
more than 14 hours the interrogation lasted and
I was not allowed to contact my
relatives and  relatives
did not provide me with any legal
assistance and  so
I was in a rather difficult
situation, let's have all the
comments tomorrow because I
just need to relax today